ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 11 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
สิงหาคมปีพศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ปีคศอะไรคะปีพ
2  0  2  2 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 10 เดือนมาถึง
เดือนสิงหาคม
ปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศ
ปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
12 เดือน
เดือน
สิงหาคม AE พ.ต.
ปีพ.ศ
2565  a คศปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะกะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา 6 โมงเช้าเย็นนเช้าอ่ะ
อีกกี่นาที
06:02 ค่ะเช้ามากสองนาทีนะคะผู้หญิงกับ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยตื่นเช้ามาๆแล้วบอกผู้หญิง
เนี่ยเป็น 19:00 นค่ะครูฟ้า
19:00 นหรอคะผู้หญิงหญิงยังไม่นอนอีก
เหรอคะ 19:00 นเองนะครับคุณฟ้าเพิ่งจะกิน
ข้าวอิ่มอุ่น
ตาแต่กูม้า
อะไรฮะ
พรุ่งนี้จะไปพรุ่งนี้นะวันศุกร์ที่ 12
สิงหาคม
ครูฟ้ารู้ไหมพรุ่งนี้วันอะไร
สิงหาคมพรุ่งนี้วันศุกร์
ค่ะ
ฉันสุขใจซะก็จะสุขวันที่วันที่ 12
สิงหาคมเนี้ยวันอะไรไม่ใช่วันศุกร์ไม่วัน
ศุกร์วันอะไรอ่ะดูฟ้าเป็นคนไม่ดีอ่ะครู
ฟ้าเป็นลูกไม่ดีทำไม่ได้จำไม่ได้ว่าวัน
ที่ 12 สิงหาคมวันอะไร
ไม่ใช่วันเกิดคุณพ่อคุณแม่ครูฟ้าว่าอะไร
แล้วก็ครูฟ้าขาววันที่ 12 สิงหาคมเนี้ย
เป็นวันแม่
นี่ไงวัน
อันนี้ครูฟ้าใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าครูฟ้าและก็มี
พ่อ
แล้วก็แม่พรุ่งนี้เนี่ยวันที่ 12 สิงหาคม
เนี่ยวันแม่
วันแม่พ่อคิดอะไรนะที่ไทยที่ไทยอ่ะหมอเทศ
ไทยเนี่ยวันแม่นะคะอ๋ออ๋อครูหญิงวันแม่
นี่เองตายครูฟ้าเนี่ยจะไม่ได้พรุ่งนี้วัน
แม่
ไม่ได้ไม่ได้นะต้องจํา
ทําไม
ทําไมอะไรคะทำไมวันแม่แล้วเราต้องทำอะไร
ให้แม่เอาคนไทยเนี่ยก็จะมีดอกไม้
อ่ะมีดอกไม้นะคะแล้วก็กูฟ้าเนาะครูป๊า
เนี่ยนะคะก็จะเอาดอกไม้เนี่ยให้คุณแม่
จอกมะลิ
ดอกมะลิได้ดอกมะลิเปิดนะว่าเปิดจะเปิดให้
ดูมันจะเป็นคนไทยเนี่ยจะมีดอกไม้นะคะดอก
ไม้เนี่ยนะเขาหอมมีสีขาวนกแนท 4 ขาวให้
คุณแม่
ไงเห็นไหมดอกมะลิดอกมะลิ 5 นักเรียน
รู้แล้วค่ะรู้แล้วโทรบอก
สูบด้วยตัวเองนะก็แต่ครู Fast เนี่ยไม่
รู้ไม่ได้นะครูฟ้าเป็นลูก
โอเคว่าต้องไปเอาดอกมะลิให้คุณแม่แล้ว
จ่ายค่ะแต่แต่ก่อนที่จะไปเนี่ยครูหญิงก็
เลยพรุ่งนี้เนี่ยเป็นวันแม่ใช่ไหมคะวัน
ที่สิบสองนาทีอ่ะเนี่ยวันนี้เนี่ยครูหญิง
ก็เลยจะมีเกมเกี่ยวกับคุณแม่
มาให้ครูฟ้าแล้วก็นักเรียนเนี่ยเล่น
เกมเกี่ยวกับคุณแม่หรอมาเล่นคนเดียวที่
นี่ไม่ต้องเล่นกับคุณแม่ใช่ไหมคะไม่ต้อง
ไม่ต้องทำไม่ต้องไม่ต้องไม่ต้องเป็นเกม
พี่
มีรูฝาผู้หญิงเนี่ยจะมีรูปตามีรูปเนี่ย
อาจจะเป็นรูปมีผู้หญิงผู้หญิงแล้วก็มี
เด็กๆมีรูปให้ครูฟ้าดูแล้วภูฟ้าต้องคิด
เอเจ้นท์บีชคนไหนเป็นแม่
ไหนเป็นแม่อุษาไม่ได้เป็นแม่ด้วยกูก็จะ
ไม่รู้ก็ได้เราไปดูรูปกันค่ะอุ้ยรู้มา
แล้วในงวดแล้วจะมั้ยไงและร่วมมีอะไรคะคือ
ฟ้าในรูปก็มีคู่มาเห็นก่อนเลยคือ 1 กับ 2
นะค่ะขอบคุณมากค่ะ
แล้วในรูปก็ยังมีผู้หญิงกับผู้หญิง 2 คน
ค่ะงือคิดว่าผู้หญิงสองคนนี้เป็นคุณแม่มะ
ก็ไม่รู้แล้วนี่ใครมีคนอยู่ในรูปด้วยมี
เด็กผู้ชาย
เด็กผู้ชายเด็กผู้ชายนะข้ารู้แล้วค่ะเด็ก
ผู้ชายเด็กผู้ชายกำลังทำอะไรคะในรูปเด็ก
ผู้ชายกำลังเล่นของเล่นอยู่ค่ะค่ะ 1 ผู้
ชายเห็นแล้วใช่ไหมคะในรูปเนี่ยมีผู้หญิง 2
คนคือ
เห็นเขาดินผู้หญิงให้คนนี้ชื่อจะชื่นมี
ผู้หญิงคนที่ 1 เนาะผู้หญิงคนที่ 1 นะก็
คือคนนี้นะตัวนี้หรือผู้หญิงคนที่ 1
แล้วก็ผู้หญิงคนที่ 2 มีผู้หญิง 2 คนนะคะ
คำถามค่ะครูฟ้า
ถามว่าอะไรถามว่าว่าครูฟ้าเห็นผู้หญิงสอง
คนใช่ไหมคะในรูปเนี่ยมีเด็กด้วยเนาะจะมี
ผู้หญิง 1 คนมีคนพี่เป็นคุณแม่ของเด็ก
สมัยเด็กก็จะมีพ่อมีแม่นะฮะค่ะคุณแม่เนาะ
วันนี้นะเป็นแม่นะคะ
ครูฟ้าฟ้าเนี่ยดูรูปแล้วคิดว่าผู้หญิง
หมายเลข 1 หรือผู้หญิงหมายเลข 2 ที่เป็น
แม่ของเด็กผู้ชายคนนี้
ช่อง
ก่อนที่ครูฟ้าจะตอบ
ค่ะกูการคิดหน้าคิดอ่ะเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงจะพูด
ให้ฟังแล้วก็ฝากก็ต้องคิด
มาดูที่ผู้หญิงหมายเลข 1 ก่อนค่ะ
เพราะว่าผู้
หญิงหมายเลข 1 เนี่ยใส่เสื้อ
ลายเนี่ยเบื่อเหมือนเด็กผู้ชายใช่ไหมค่ะ
ใส่เสื้อลายเหมือนกัน
จะเป็นแม่
เจอกันก็ได้เพราะว่าคนไทยคนเอเชียเนี่ย
ถ้าเป็นครอบครัวเดียวกันเนาะอ.แม่ลูกบาง
ครั้งก็จะใส่เสื้อเหมือนกันเมื่อชายผู้
หญิงคนนี้ก็จะเป็นแม่ก็ได้แต่
คุณแม่จะใส่รองเท้าส้นสูงหรอ
เพราะว่าลูบก็ยังเด็กๆอยู่น่าจะประมาณ 4
ขวบ
แม่เขาส่วนสุขหรออ่ะมิคนที่ 1 นะคะฟ้าค่ะ
มาคนที่สองคนที่สองเนี่ยก็ไม่ได้ใส่เสื้อ
เหมือนกันแต่ว่าคนที่สองเนี่ยหน้าเนี่ย
เขาก็มองเด็กตลอดเวลาเนอะ
แล้วเด็กเนี่ยก็หันหน้าหาผู้หญิงหมายเลข 2
ด้วยเพราะว่าเด็กเนี่ยเขาจะหันหน้าให้กับ
คนที่เขารู้จักเท่านั้นถ้าไม่รู้จะหมอเขา
จะไม่คุยด้วยใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วก็ผู้หญิงคนนี้เนี่ยก็ไม่ได้ใส่รอง
เท้าส้นสูงเออแต่ผู้หญิงคนนี้ที่หันหน้า
มองเด็กอาจจะเพราะว่าผู้หญิงน่ะเป็นคน
รับเด็กก็ได้ก็ไม่รู้นะค่ะอ่ะครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ฝั่งครูหญิงพูดแล้วครูฟ้าคิดว่า
คนผู้หญิงคนที่ 1 หรือผู้หญิงคนที่สอง
เป็นแม่
โปรไฟล์คิดว่าถ้านั้นแท้ๆคิดว่าคิดว่าคิด
ว่าเหยื่อ
คิดเยอะจังกูไม่คิดว่าผู้หญิง
คนที่ไหน 3
ไม่มี
ผู้หญิงสองคนคนที่ 1 กับฮะคนที่สองเท่า
นั้นผู้หญิงคนที่ 3 คือคนนี้เหรอ
อุ้ย
ไม่ได้นะคะกูคิดว่าผู้หญิงคนที่ 1 ค่ะ
ทำไม้ทำไมครูฟ้าคิดว่าผู้หญิงคนที่ 1
เป็นแม่ของเด็ก
เดาค่ะ
เดาแต่ก็ต้องคิดสิ 1  2  1  2  1  2  1  2
1  2  1 ว่าช่องเลข 11 หนึ่ง
กูป่าวไม่คิดอะไรเลยพูดโอเคผู้หญิงคนที่ 1
ก็คิดว่าหนา
ถูกฟ้าค่ะคิดว่ารู้ฟ้าคิดว่าผู้หญิงคนที่
1 เป็นแม่
ว่าเสื้อเหมือนกันนะคะแล้วก็ผู้หญิงบอก
สวยเสื้อเหมือนกันอยู่ก็ตอบหนึ่งพวกไว้
เห็นเสื้อนั่นแหละตั้งแต่เต็มเลยแต่ว่า
ว่าคิดว่า
คุณแม่อาจจะดูผู้หญิงนี่มาคือเค้าก็จะมอง
อ่ะเขาจะกลัวผิดนี้อ่ะอะไรลูกฉันหรือ
เปล่าไปล้างฟ้าเนี่ยหลานกูฟ้าเวลาเล่นของ
เล่นนะคะกูค่ะมีหลานนะคะนักเรียน
ว่า
พ่อคุณแม่ใช่ไหมแล้วก็ครูปลาแล้วก็วันนี้
ก็จะแต่งงานแล้วก็ไม่รู้แล้วก็คนนี้แหละ
แต่งงานแล้วก็มีลูกเด็กคนนี้เนี่ยเป็น
หลานครูฟ้า
งายเวลาหลานค่ะฟ้าเล่นของเล่นเนี่ยเล่น
ของเล่นนะคะเขาจะไม่อยู่ไม่สนใจไม่ดูใคร
เลยว่าจะเล่นอยู่คนเดียวเลยเนี้ยอาจจะไม่
รู้ตัวมั้งก็ไม่ออกแม่ไม่ได้มองแม่
ก็เลยคิดว่าอาจจะเป็นคนนี้หรือเปล่าว่า
เดาค่ะต่อ
ปากก้อนก็คิดว่าผู้หญิงหมายเลข 1 เนาะ
หมายเลข 1 เนี่ยเป็นคุณแม่มาเค้าอุ้ย
ไปหาผู้หญิงเป็นคุณแม่นะคะรูฟ้าขา
ครูค่ะหาเนี่ยเป็นลูกไม่ดีตอบคุณแม่ไม่
ได้จำวันแม่ไม่ได้เจอ
แล้ว
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็ยังไม่มีความเป็นแม่ความ
เป็นแม่เนี่ยศูนย์เปอร์เซ็นต์ว่าจะมีความ
เป็นแม่ได้ยังไง
เพราะไม่ใช่ยังไม่เห็นง่ายนะครับ
เมื่อว่างกูมาหากูไม่มีความเป็นแม่ก็คือ
ฟ้าแบบกูบ้างไม่ได้เป็นแม่นะแต่กูฟ้าเป็น
ผู้หญิงหรือใช่ไหมมีผู้หญิงเนี่ยเกิดมา
เพื่อเป็นแม่ที่คนไทยคิดนะว่าไทยเมื่อ
ก่อนคิดใช่ไหมผู้หญิงก็เป็นคุณแม่ไงแต่กู
ฟ้าเนี่ยไม่มีนะคะไม่มีใครเข้าผู้หญิง
ทำไมฟ้าตอบ
ผิดถ้าไม่ทิ้งจริงทำไมอ่ะ it ถ้าผู้หญิง
คนที่ 1 เนี่ยไม่ใช่คุณแม่ฟ้าคุณคุยแต่
นี่มันจริงนะไม่คุณแม่ที่มีลูกอายุประมาณ
นี้ค่ะมากๆนะอาจจะซัก 90 เปอร์เซ็นต์
เนี่ยเขาไม่ค่อยใส่รองเท้าส้นสูงวิ่งทำ
ไม่ทันใช่ใช่ถ้าข้ารองเท้าส้นสูงมันอาจจะ
จะต้องเป็นส้นที่แบบเนี้ย
เด็กไปเลย
ต้นด้านหนาวิ่งได้นะคะเพราะว่าเด็กไงเด็ก
ยังเด็กมากๆอันนี้ไม่ใช่ทุกคนนะแต่ส่วน
ใหญ่
ค่ะน้องคำตอบที่ถูกก็คือผู้หญิงคนที่ 3
คนนี้ค่ะไออ่ะเป็นคุณแม่ก็อยู่ใกล้เด็ก
น้อยที่สุด
ผู้หญิงคนที่ 2 ค่ะเป็นแม่
โอ๊ตวิ่งคนที่ 2
กูฟ้ารู้ไหมทำไม
ทำไมไม่ต้องใกล้ไม่ต้องพูดใกล้ใบโพธิ์โฟน
ขนาดนั้นก็ได้ค่ะ
ทำไมฮะเอาก็บอกแล้วว่าเห็นไหมผู้หญิงคน
ที่ 1 แหละเขาจะนั่งหลังเนี่ยพิมพ์พิง
เก้าอี้
พอดีมันก็จะนั่งสบายแบบพิงพอดีแต่แม่น่ะ
เห็นไหมเขาจะนั่งแล้วก็โน้มตัวมาข้างหน้า
จะมานมตัวมาเท่าไหร่ไม่ได้พิงพอดีนี่ว่า
แม่เนี่ยจะดูรูปตลอดเวลาคนเป็นและก็จะแบบ
นี้รู้จะโอเคไหมลูกจะหยิบของเล่นเข้าปาก
ไหมรูปจะวิ่งไปไหนหรือเปล่ารู้จะไปตีใคร
ไหมแม่เนี่ยเขาจะหลับห่วงเขาจะมอง
มองลูกตลอดเวลาก็เลยว่าผู้หญิงคนที่ 2
เนี่ยเป็นแม่แล้วแต่อันนี้เนี่ยเขาก็บอก
ไปว่าเด็กส่วนใหญ่เนี่ยก็จะหันหน้าหาคน
ที่ตัวเองรู้จักด้วยไง
แม่
เขาก็เลยบอกว่าผู้หญิงคนที่ 2 เนี่ยคือ
แม่หนู
แล้วแต่ผู้หญิงคนนี้ใส่ชุดสีเขียวเอาเอง
ใช่เรียนลูกเสือกางเกงสีเขียวเอ้าทำไมไม่
ใส่เสื้อให้เหมือนลูกล่ะไม่นอนจะก็ได้
นี้
เนี่ยอ่ะค่ะเขาก็บอกว่าคนที่สองเนี่ยคิด
ถึงแม่นักเรียนคิดว่าคนที่สองเป็นแม่ไหม
หรือว่านักเรียนคิดเหมือนถูกกว่าไม่คิด
หนูฟ้าใหม่ว่าตาแล้วก็ดูสิเห็นนะคะก็ได้
คิดแปลว่าคนนี้คนนี้เป็นแม่แล้วคนนี้เป็น
ลูกหรือเปล่าเพราะว่าผมเหมือนกัน S ไส้
สัตว์ผู้หญิงคนที่ 1 กับผู้หญิงคนที่ 2
เขาน่าจะเป็นเพื่อนกัน
ตั้งแต่แบบจริงๆไม่ต้องดูไม่ต้องดูรอง
เท้า
ไม่ต้องดูว่าเด็กนั่งหันหน้าเข้าหาใครนะ
ดูคนเนี้ยว่าเวลาคนเป็นแม่น่ะจะมองลูก
ตลอดเวลาเพราะว่าจะทำอะไรไหมล่ะคนที่สอง
ก็เลยเป็นแม่กูป่าวิ่งก็องครูฟ้าถูกนะคะ
ฟ้าผิดค่ะ
เติมสาวไม่รู้ว่าใครเป็นแม่
ใช่ค่ะนะเรียนไม่เรียนรู้ไหมถ้านักเรียน
มีความเป็นแม่ไหม
ครูหญิงแน่นะคะตอนครูหญิงเล่นแหละผู้หญิง
ก็ไม่รู้ค่ะว่าใครเป็นแม่อุ้ยก็เลื่อนลง
มาแล้วก็อ่านแล้วเขาก็บอกก็คนที่สองเป็น
แน่
หึผู้หญิงก็เลยรู้แล้วใส่ค่ะเออนั่นแหละ
ก็เลยบอกว่าคนที่สองเนี่ยเป็นแม่นะคะแล้ว
ก็อ้าว
แล้วเหรอครับพรุ่งนี้นะแพงประเทศไทยเนี่ย
นะคะวันที่ 12 สิงหาคม
ก็จะเป็นวันแม่ใช่ไหมค่ะเย้วันแม่ร้านผู้
หญิงแล้วเป็นลูกหน้าตาใหญ่วันแม่ว่าเราจะ
มีดอกไม้
ดอกไม้เนี่ยให้คุณแม่แล้วหือคนไทยเนี่ยนะ
คะกับคุณพ่อคุณแม่ลูกลูกก็จะไปมากินข้าว
ด้วยกัน
ใช่มันครอบครัวถ่ายก็จะพาคุณแม่ไปกินข้าว
นะคะหาในนามีฟ้าวันแม่เนี่ยคนไทยบอกรัก
แม่ไหมหนูรักแม่ค่ะ
ผู้ว่าไม่พูดนะผู้หญิงก็ไม่พูดนะคะแต่บาง
คนก็พูดนะหนูไร่นะค่ะเงินเขาบอกว่ารักแม่
ใช่ไหมรักแม่
ตายไม่บอกรักแม่ได้อ้ะบอกรักแม่ได้
บางคนก่อนพอวันแม่คนไทยเนาะก็กอดใช่ไหม
ก่อนคุณแม่กลัวคนไทยเนี่ยไม่ได้กอดคุณแม่
ทุกๆวันแล้วก็คอร์ดแม่นะคะก็กอดคุณแม่นะ
คะค่ะก็เพื่อนแวะบ้านขอไอคนไทยเนาะอายกอด
แม่วันแม่ก็กอดแล้วก็บอกรักแม่ก็เป็นแม่
ของคนไทยหาที่จะไปนี้ไม่ใช่แล้วก็นัก
เรียนน่ะประเทศนักเรียนไม่รู้ว่าวันแม่
ผ่านไปหรือยังวันแม่วันที่เท่าไหร่แล้ว
นักเรียนทำอะไรในวันแม่ก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเรา
ได้เนาะแต่ว่าไงโอนี้นะคะครูหญิงกับครู
ฟ้าจะไป
กอดคุณแม่ก่อนนะคะได้อยู่
เจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะถ้า